you had an interesting point you've made
that both Vladimir zielinski and uh
Putin are thinking about
they're just politicians they're
thinking about the 2024 election which
is coming up for both of them yeah I've
said that in some of the other
interviews yeah that's true that's so
interesting yeah I mean because that
election is going to be pretty much at
the same time as the U.S election also
oh those will be before I mean because
sometime in that you know early part of
the year for the presidential election
yeah and also I don't know if you know
about U.S elections but they actually
last way longer we're in it now aren't
we you know already starting so there's
going to be a significant overlap
um yeah you know do you think that
actually comes into play in their
calculus I think it was one of the
reasons why Putin invaded in February of
2022 because it was gonna be two years I
mean he thought it'd be over by March of
2022 and he got two years to prepare for
you know the election and you've got a
big boost you know not only you've got a
boost from Crimea I mean I didn't
mention that before I mean one of the
reasons for inverting Crimea and
addicting or invading Ukraine the first
time Alex in crime it was look what
happened to his ratings they went from
kind of declining it was still pretty
good you know by anybody's standards too
just rocketing off into the stratosphere
I mean I didn't really meet anybody in
Russia who thought that Alex in Crimea
was you know kind of a bad thing
I mean even you know kind of people who
were opposed putting on so many other
things Crimea was you know Crim Nash
they kept saying you know this is kind
of you know we got it back you know it
should never have gone away it was ours
you know and but you know this is more
complex and he wasn't I don't think at
the time planning on annexing all of
Ukraine uh when he went in this special
military operation he was going to try
to turn it into what Belarus has become
a part of a you know bring back the
Commonwealth of independent states or
the union then a new Union with Belarus
and Ukraine and Russia over time but
certainly you know remove Ukraine is a
major factor independent Factor on the
world stage and you know consolidate
Crimea and maybe you know kind of
incorporate daniette's you know kind of
that was that was also a possibility but
it wasn't
it wasn't in his intention and it gets
to have something on this kind of scale
he wanted to get on with them preparing
for what was going to be he would think
the cake walk the shoe-in of the next
presidential election I mean last time
around he had to invite a bit of
competition with this person who's
reputed to be his goddaughter Cindy
subject you know to put a bit of you
know a kind of entertainment for people
you know the sex time around you know
maybe he wasn't really planning on
running you know against any other you
know serious opposition he was just
going to have the Acclaim of you know
the kind of the the great leader like
President XI
um in China you know Putin you know was
basically I think you know he also hoped
that he would be able to devolve some
Authority away you know kind of so he's
more like the you know the supreme
leader kind of figure the Tsar like
figure the Monarch and then you know
other people get on with the chief
executive prime minister or running the
country and he could kind of like step
back and just enjoy this you know maybe
there was going to be again a new Union
of Belarus Russia and
um then Ukraine and some you know
fashion and he would preside over that